good sunday morning for today you want
to keep that umbrella handy and secure
all of those loose objects patio
furniture specifically because we do
have a wind advisory in full effect we
will also be seeing more
mountain snow and add to that we will
tell you that the below normal
temperatures will continue for today to
be exact
14 degrees away from those 70 degree
temperatures
where we should be this time of year
those lows for tonight will be
in the 40s and boy it's getting to be a
lot chillier
satellite radar will tell you more about
that second
colder system that's pushing through
drops from the pacific northwest
and what it's doing it's bringing three
to six inches of snow above 5000 feet
add to that we're talking rain chances
for today
less than a tenth of an inch for most of
your areas
we are crossing our fingers hopefully we
can break that dry spell
futurecast will show you that activity
pushing through this morning the best
chances for rain back again
starting at 10 a.m all the way into that
four o'clock hour
after that we do expect rain chances to
slim down quite a bit
into the 20 percent chance and then you
could see all of that activity pushes
towards the east of us
dry conditions pushing back again
starting on monday
tuesday we'll start to notice some
clouds for veterans day and then
eventually
on friday tracking another system as of
right now
we're checking to see if it's going to
bring us some chances for rain wind
speeds we'll also show you today they
will be
on the rise those southwest winds
stronger gusting for the afternoon you
can see just how colorful
our maps represent all of that gusts
baker 31 miles per hour prim at 34
boulder city in the 30s
for that 3 o'clock hour you can see
kingman at 29 miles per hour
this will continue those gusts could
peak all the way up to 45 miles per hour
they will become a little bit more
tranquil
for your monday after that what's headed
for today 8 a.m start in the 50s you can
see partly cloudy skies before we
increase
to 54 56 not as much as we would like to
but we do have those rain chances
kicking in starting at 10 a.m
the next few days we will be clearing
out but below normal temperatures will
remain you can see 58 degrees around
your tuesday
and if you're heading out to the
mountains for today those highs will be
in the 30s extremely cold
a 50 percent chance of snow showers
southwest winds will be staying 20 to 30
miles per hour
red rock really cold up there 45
degrees highs for the lake 61 degrees 70
shower chances as well so rain will be
likely
southwest winds will be staying 20 to 30
miles per hour boaters beware
choppy waters over two feet tonight
flows in the 40s a slim
chance of rain before that 10 o'clock
hour and you can see those winds will
become a little bit more tranquil for
tonight here's your sally j seven day
forecast
where we do track below normal
temperatures lots of sunshine and
clearing and you could see their
veterans stay with 61 degrees
62 on friday and those lows very chilly
back to you